hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead finale video just
careful for spoilers for pee pants City
if you haven't seen it yet they totally
did the nican comic book introduction
but I feel like people are gonna be just
as mad for the things that they did not
do in the episode that's always a really
interesting proposition when you have
this big WTF finale and you do some
really awesome things but you also
withhold some of the payoff so we can
talk about that as we dig through Easter
eggs and WTF moments there is a new
round of the giveaway I'll talk about
that at the end of the video so here we
go top 10 WTF number 10 Morgan rides in
like a boss on a horse
very nice callback to season 1 when Rick
wrote in to Atlanta on a horse we don't
find out who the horse belongs to till
the end of the episode but we'll talk
about that in a second because it's
really interesting set up for next
season he's still looking for Carroll
number 9 WTF finds her licking her
wounds and she is in the same old
runaround speech about how she can't be
around people she loves because she'll
be forced to kill and if you can't do
that you can't stick around in this
stuff she says is in direct opposition
to the stuff that Rick is saying through
the episode we've survived this whole
time because we've been together we can
do anything together and Carol's like no
I got to be on my own even Morgan is
like you're going to die on your own
number 7 WTF she almost does die on her
own when the Savior that she failed to
kill in the car finally catches up to
her you may detected it because you were
anticipating certain things or just in
the literal text of the episode but
there was this heavy vibe of will they
won't they in the episode in the will
they won't they of the Carroll storyline
was will Morgan kill to save Carroll if
all life is precious and he's sworn off
killing completely being the Carroll
storyline took her so far away from what
was going on with the larger savior
group I figured she was safe from negan
about halfway through the episode so I
was like yeah she's definitely gonna
survive
Morgan is totally gonna have to kill
this person but then number 6 WTF we
find out who owned the horse it's the
guy that Morgan stopped Rick from
killing previously just looking at the
armor you can kind of tell that he's
from one of the other big groups in the
comics that we haven't met yet but they
will probably be meeting next season
because that's where they're taking
Carroll right now I guess for now we can
just say it's the kingdom this seems
like season seven is definitely doing
the kingdom we can talk more about them
down the road but please use spoiler
if you've read ahead in the comics and
you know all about that group of people
as you can see though they're really
nice and they're armored to the teeth so
think of them as being the diametric
opposite of the saviors with the
survivors caught in between them but
isn't it funny how heavy-handed they get
with their metaphors where it's like if
Morgan had done the Rick thing and
killed him then they wouldn't be there
to get medical help for Carol so in that
case not killing really good move on the
other side of that coin Darryl not
killing Dwight really bad decision so
it's almost like you're screwed no
matter what you do speaking of which
number five the RV just keeps running
into road block after road block after
road block
I love the way each successive road
block just got worse and worse and worse
until they finally got to the one that
had some of their friends possessions on
them like oh my god it's one of them is
Shone's dreadlocks
it's some of Darrell's belongings you
just see that look on Rick's face and
they just keep pushing on but they're
under a half a tank of gas it's turning
in tonight so number four WTF Eugene has
a plan and this is really when I started
to get worried about Eugene being the
one to get loose sealed when he gave
them the recipe for making bullets I'm
like ooh that's powerful he gets this
nice send-off from Abraham you're
survivor we just didn't know it so you
can kind of feel the riders giving him a
bit of a send-off like he's gonna ride
off into the sunset never to be seen
again but number three WTF has the group
takes Maggie through the woods you start
to hear all the whistles and they get
caught oh [ __ ] it didn't work number two
WTF intro to negan hi I'm negan they
pretty much lined them up just like they
are in the comics the way negan speaks
that whole speech of his and it goes on
for a long time this is all issue 100 of
the comic just paged a screen Jeffrey
Dean Morgan totally looks the part I
can't wait to see him he's a great actor
and I feel like he did a pretty good job
with what they gave him in this scene
the brief time that we did see him all
say if you haven't read the comics you
haven't seen anything yet
he's so much more spectacularly bad than
this episode made him out to be it's
gonna be so much fun next season number
one WTF and I think a lot of you guys
will agree is the way they paid off that
death at the end so no spoilers from the
comics certain character dies I think
that he is also the person whose
perspective we're viewing this from -
but they didn't switch perspective to
show us who it was
so I could just see everyone shaking
their fists like everyone's blood
pressure is already through the roof
just because of the 2001 Space Odyssey
intro that negan got it really did sound
like that song from 2001 Space Odyssey
when he was coming out of the RV thus
spake Zarathustra it's almost like the
show is evolving just like that primates
are evolving in 2001 Space Odyssey only
instead of a bone banging against the
obelisk negan's banging against
someone's head with Lucille so just in
the interest of avoiding rampant
spoilers let me know do you think that
the comic-book person that gets Lucille
also got Lucille's on the TV show do you
think the person that dies in the comic
book is the person that died on the TV
show very clearly they're all giving us
the middle finger from behind the screen
making us wait to find out but for those
that are wondering even though they
haven't officially confirmed season 7
episode 1 will probably premiere the
same time Walking Dead always premieres
every year in the middle of October so
most of the cast reactions have been
that it's going to be a long summer just
like oh man I can't believe we're gonna
have to wait to find out and I'm really
curious to find out if they actually
filmed the scene and they just filmed it
from different perspectives and we'll
just wait to show the rest of that
footage to the premiere or if this is
the only way they shot it and even the
actors don't know who's gonna be the
actual person to get Lucille but some
really awesome things in the finale some
other things that I didn't like quite so
much the Carroll stuff could have
probably been done in last week's
episode and been a little more
appropriate they could have just done
the RV versus the Savior's it would have
been a much tighter episode I felt like
that would have been a perfect episode
just that stuff it would have made the
episode like an hour long instead of
being an hour and a half when that extra
half-hour worth that Carol stuff didn't
really need to be in there but let me
know if you agree do you think that they
should have cut out the Carol stuff and
put that in a different episode and just
done the negan Savior stuff in this
episode even if they were never going to
show us who was actually getting killed
that's still a bit of a WTF they had
said that there was going to be a
cliffhanger at the end of the season
they just didn't say what kind of a
cliffhanger so even though it kind of
sucks I felt like they were trying to
give us all the comic book negan intro
stuff without completely blowing their
wad if you are reading along in the
comics though this negan stuff the issue
100 stuff happens during the end of vol
17 something to fear I think most of
season 7 is going to come from volume 18
of the comics what comes after
so if you want to read ahead read volume
18 before season seven starts giveaway
time congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner spy soldier you win a
$20 Amazon gift card just be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel it's just on the about page and
there is a new round of the giveaway
starting now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video because they did tease a
couple really big things for next season
in this episode like the kingdom I'll do
a predictions video next because there
are a couple big comic book things that
I'm pretty sure that they're gonna do
they're actually sticking pretty close
to the comics now especially with all
this negan stuff so if you have any
friends who have quit the show now's the
time to get them back on because negan
is gonna be so much fun next season not
really my favorite finale but definitely
my favorite intro for a character just
been being so faithful for a negan's
intro why you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn a little bit about negan's
backstory edges I talked about it during
the negan trailer video and you can
click here to learn about my favorite
game of Thrones characters that the TV
show has cut out thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight